[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 y ya está con nosotros el estudio
Jorge Hurtado Jorge buena mañana
iniciamos en China porque Dejó de ser el
motor del crecimiento de Asia esto
precisamente por su política de covid
cero esta y otra circunstancias harán
que por primera vez desde 1990 la
segunda economía mundial crezca por
debajo de la media de la región un 2,8%
frente al 5,3% regional un informe del
Banco Mundial que fue publicado hoy
rebajó su predicción de crecimiento del
producto interno bruto de China para
2022 al mismo tiempo las expectativas
para el resto de Asia Oriental y el
Pacífico han mejorado se espera que la
región excluyendo china crezca un 5,3%
en 2022 frente al 2,6 del año pasado
esto gracias a los altos precios de las
materias primas y el repunte del consumo
interno tras la pandemia los principales
indicadores económicos de China
apuntaron a un buen inicio de año tanto
que las autoridades de ese país marcaron
un marzo Con un objetivo de crecimiento
del 5,5% para este año una tasa que cayó
en el segundo trimestre a consecuencia
de los estrictos confinamientos
ordenados por el gobierno para enfrentar
los peores rebrotes de Kobe 19 en dos
años que ha vivido ese país y Jorge en
el comercio internacional también hay
pesimismo es que las previsiones del
comercio mundial podrían realizarse a la
baja desde el actual 3% para 2022 esto
lo dijo la directora general de la
Organización Mundial del Comercio gosi o
conyo la funcionaria citó la actual
guerra entre Rusia y Ucrania y la crisis
alimentaria así como el aumento de los
precios de la energía que van en aumento
la Organización Mundial del Comercio Ya
revisó a la baja su previsión de
crecimiento del comercio mundial para
este año hasta el 3% desde el 4,7% que
tenían previsto en abril también se
prevé un crecimiento del 3,4% en 2023 y
a reacciones en Reino Unido tras las
reformas en el nuevo gobierno el nuevo
ministro de finanzas
británico kasawe quarting anunció una
histórica reducción de impuestos y un
enorme aumento del endeudamiento algo
que agitó los mercados e hizo caer la
libre esterlina en mínimos históricos
frente al dólar en resumen eliminó el
tipo máximo del impuesto sobre la renta
del país canceló una subida prevista del
impuesto de sociedades y puso precio a
los planes del gasto de la primera
ministra listross que quiere duplicar la
tasa de crecimiento económico de Reino
Unido el plan para subvenciones o para
subvencionar las facturas energéticas
que es uno de los mayores problemas
junto con la inflación costará 60.000
millones de libras solo en los próximos
seis meses mientras que los recortes
Fiscales que se anunciaron costarán
otros 45 mil millones de libras
esterlinas hasta el año 2026 la libra
esterlina se estabilizó en el mercado
asiático mientras el banco de Inglaterra
y el gobierno británico intentaban
calmar a los mercados escuchemos Y qué
opinan ahí de estos cambios
increíble obviamente quiero decir la
gente que es pobre ahora mismo que tiene
ingresos bajos está luchando están
luchando con su calefacción y todas sus
facturas todo ha subido porque demonios
se recorta para la gente con mayores
ingresos Es ridículo Londres está
empeorando así que si es una medida
estúpida una medida tonta obviamente
pero también nos quedamos Jorge en
Inglaterra porque el banco ya dio fecha
para ver la imagen en el nuevo rey
Carlos en los billetes para hacer hasta
mediados del año 2024 la nueva imagen se
dará a conocer a finales de este año
actualmente en circulación hay unos 11
mil millones de billetes el rostro de la
Reina Isabel ha estado en los billetes
de Reino Unido desde el año
1960 la nueva serie en billetes también
llevaría la imagen de algunos personajes
como Wilson Churchill
y vamos a venirnos a nuestra región
Jorge porque continúa las reacciones
tras la reapertura de la fronteras entre
Colombia y Venezuela bueno los países
vuelven a estar Unidos en esta frontera
común la economía de ambos países serán
beneficiados con la reapertura
fronteriza porque permitirá la libre
circulación terrestre de bienes
principalmente que Colombia produce y
que Venezuela necesita como alimentos
productos farmacéuticos y algunos
artículos de aseo en Colombia esperan la
generación de 10.000 empleos directos e
indirectos en los próximos tres meses
por el esperado aumento del intercambio
comercial el comercio bilateral tocoso
máximo en 2008 con 7.200 millones de
dólares pero colapsó tras el cierre
fronterizo que duró siete años ahora
Nicolás Maduro Espera que el alcance o
que se alcancen los 2.000 millones de
dólares este año en intercambios
comerciales escuchemos que decía
le envió al presidente Gustavo Petro y
el agradecimiento de más de 30 millones
de venezolanos y venezolanas
por este paso
inmenso que hemos dado
para restituir
las relaciones de hermandad de Unión de
cooperación de complementariedad
entre nuestros pueblos Jorge para
finalizar que tenemos como cifra del día
te gusta el trabajo remoto me gusta el
trabajo remoto Solo que nosotros se
puede hacer bueno para algunos es bueno
y para otro Es malo de aquí el dato de
la cifra del día el 60% impulsó el
trabajo remoto los precios de la
vivienda en Estados Unidos una
investigación del banco de la reserva
Federal de San Francisco reveló que los
últimos dos años los precios aumentaron
un 24%. Los investigadores dicen que el
aumento del trabajo a distancia puede
afectar en el futuro los precios de los
inmuebles y también la inflación según
ellos cada aumento de un punto
porcentual en el trabajo remoto
representa un 0,9 puntos porcentuales en
el precio de las viviendas en ese país
bueno Jorge gracias por toda la
información economía como siempre más
adelante más economía Pero antes vamos a
pasar a saludar a Luis Méndez con los
deportes Gracias Jorge
[Música]